for the tampa bay rays tonight it's
going to be left-hander ryan yarbrough
making his 19th start of the season the
record 7-4 era 4.57 and 128 innings of
work
and that will be strength three call
to start this game let's say that's the
other thing for ryan yarbrough against
this lineup is mixing those pitches he
did a great job against renfrow saw a
number of the change-ups a number of
cutters a traditional fastball that
change up right there you can see renfro
not even getting out of that stance not
looking for that pitch at all
under this one and he skies it not
overly deep to right center
and rosarito waiting on it makes the
grab
jd coming off one for four last night
has put together a little three-game
hitting streak
and at it again that's a fair ball down
the line that's going to keep on
bouncing up against the short fence
jd for second base
and continues his hit parade against
yarbrough boy he tried to get it in on
him again but he cleaned it out
a little soft little cutter just
spinning right there gets the barrel to
it hooks it right down the line and
here's another guy who has just eaten up
yarbrough there are plenty of them in
the red sox lineup xander is a 407
hitter against him 11 for 27. martinez
second base and the 3-2
and a base hit into right field
jd heads the 30s trying to score here's
the throw by rosarian up the line and
the red sox are on the board rbi hit
from xander bogarts his 70th run bad and
the red sox strike first and he waited
he didn't try to pull he did not try to
pull just acquired brad peacock
swinging at the first pitch just as he
did last night but a much different
result because this would be caught by
verdugo home run last night for lau on
the first pitch from nick pavetta
so it's going to be served the other way
little looper dalbeck will go out and
get it in fair territory two down
dalmach will take that right to the base
and that's a nice quick start for brad
peacock he gets them one two three
our ooze is now in the ball game
at short xander bogarts is out of the
ball game no idea why at this point he's
had the one at bat where he had the rbi
single he was out there in a defensive
position after this rbi single
and then alex cora
waved him back in
that was right at the beginning of this
half inning yeah that's not good
one man away
rosa rainey will be the batter the right
fielder 274 17 home runs one of their
hottest hitters right now
oh there's a shot off the band of a rose
arena and that one is
gone
number 18 for rosarina
and the raids have tied this game with
one swing of his back well brad peacock
the sweeping slider
and it doesn't sweep it spins and it
stays middle if you had any doubt all
you had to do was take a look at kyle
schwarber out there in left field i
don't even think that he moved
they're loaded
with one out for wander franco
he lines it into right that's a base hit
kirmarn's going to score they're going
to stop mejia the throw is wide and
that's going to go all the way to the
front of the dugout allowing mejia to
come home after that base hit to drive
in the run and the rays get two out of
that and take a three to one lead
here's a pitch bounding all the way to
the backstop and up the screen
and the rays will get another run it's a
wild pitch
with no attempt and a block there by
vasquez and that's what makes it really
difficult
ground ball that's gonna go through the
right side pants dahlbach
another round is in franco crosses the
plate meadows picking up his 93rd run
batted in and it's 5-1
graves
in on him and he pops it into short
right
on the run that ball's gonna drop in
front of renfro one around his head here
comes another man the raves are going to
score all three as a rosarito crosses
the plate diaz drops that one into short
right and the raised lead is now 7-1
schwarber leading it off he's flying out
grounded out tonight
schwarber drives one high and deep into
right center field it's going to carry
carry and it's gone home run for kyle
schwarber number 28. oh boy he got it
you see enough of those little frisbees
you're gonna get on one
fly ball left center verdugo
moving to his right he'll make the catch
and the tag for diaz he's going to score
and the raves on the sacrifice fly to
center pick up their eighth run of the
night it's 8-2
ground ball that's
stopped by lau he's got to play it first
nicely done
shaded that way to begin with that he
reigns even more to his left
to get the out at first with the runners
moving to second and third
to gone now
there's a shot and a base hit that'll
pick up an rbi
schwarber in to score
it's an 8-3 game 97 rbis for raphael
he just slashed that high fastball the
other way a little late doesn't matter
fly ball center field here comes
kiermeier to make the catch
to retire the side
one run that's it eight three rays
that's a high fly ball into left
meadows
will be there and make the catch for the
out
hot shot and a fair ball
down the line it rolls around chugging
his way into third he'll stop there be a
double anorenfro has two hits in his
return two ringing doubles tonight
2-2 hammered and a base hit
one run into score renfro be stopped at
third that makes it eight to four
kyle schwarber with an rbi hit second
rbi tonight
hammers that one for a base hit that'll
drive it a run
renfro will score
and that makes it eight to five show you
a second there you go it's getting
interesting here
and the pitch he got may stretch him out
fastball to end it
goes down swinging to put this one into
the win column for the rays